when I first started cyberpunk Edge
Runners I thought oh cool they included
locations from cyberpunk 2077 like the
Memorial Park near arasaka Tower with
the holographic koi fish or of course
important locations like the afterlife
bar so it seemed like a great idea to
make a video of all the major locations
in cyberpunk 2077 that were featured in
Edge Runners and in doing research and
some exploration that was when I
discovered that the number of locations
shown at Edge Runners that you can find
in cyberpunk 2077 is
staggering in fact after working on this
video I think it might be possible that
pretty much every single shot is
somewhere you can actually find in
cyberpunk 2077 so here is mapping out
cyberpunk Edge Runners for this part
I'll only be focusing on the first five
episodes of the anime if you guys
enjoyed this let me know so I know to go
ahead and make a second episode with the
second half of the anime I've split it
into two parts because there is just
that much you can find in the game so
let's start with episode one and go
scene by scene also before I get into
this I want to give credit to volk.com
which is how I found most of these I
seriously have no idea how they found a
lot of these so they really deserve a
lot of credit here Edge runner's first
episode begins with a BD of a cyber
psycho attack this attack takes place at
the center of corpo Plaza around the
Memorial Park it's Ultra memorable
thanks to the koi fish Hollow floating
around
[Music]
foreign
Martinez's apartment this apartment is
pretty much identical to V's starting
Apartments
on TV we see the exact location and
crime scene of where the Cyber psycho
was taken down this is right across the
street from the Memorial Park Metro
Station
from here David takes his walk to school
once he heads outside of the apartment
complex we see this shot which reveals
David's location David is in Santo
Domingo and lives in mega building H4
with this in-game shot of the location
being identical
foreign
this is also where the edge Runners
patched in side quest is located where
you'll find a BD and eventually be able
to get David's jacket
we can also spot the various locations
from David's Walk David is heading from
his apartment to the wollison street
rapid transit station along the Route
you can spot the exact intersection
where the armed robbery is taking place
and Wilson Street Rapid Transit is
exactly the same in the show as it is in
the game
David gets off at the Memorial Park
Metro Station and as I mentioned earlier
passes by the crime scene
he then heads up the Central Plaza
stairs where he spots Lucy runs up and
once again we can see this exact
location where Lucy seems to disappear
David then jogs over to arasaka Tower
another prominent feature of corpo Plaza
after school David's mother Gloria
drives him home back from corpo Plaza to
Santa Domingo they're stuck in traffic
and get caught in the crosshairs of a
shootout
as we now know thanks to mapping all of
this out the yellow and blue building
you can see in the distance is Mega
building H4 meaning they were almost
home
foreign
end up in a hospital right afterwards
amazingly even this interior can be
found in the game but in game is
actually a psych ward and the location
of the gig Cuckoo's Nest which uh
automatically started for me as I was
trying to get this footage so another
mission knocked out thanks to mapping
this out then game location for this is
in Rancho Coronado
at the end of the episode David decides
to go to his Ripper doc to get implanted
Davis Ripper dock is also located in
Santo Domingo Northwest of Mega building
H4
foreign
mostly wrapped up so let's dive into
episode two after wandering around
aimlessly David runs into Lucy on the
Metro they get off at the Memorial Park
station in corpo Plaza where David
faints
[Music]
Lucy and David escaping from the
ambulance is in Japan Town in the
Westbrook area
Lucy's apartment also happens to be in
Japan Town Westbrook near the river in
fact here's the exact spot they look at
at together
which apartment is Lucy's is a good
question as it could be many days or it
could be Mega building h8 so I did a
little exploration in order to try and
figure this out as best I could while I
am talking about episode 2 I'm using the
end of episode 4 when David and Lucy are
on the roof for a reference I tried to
access the roof of Mega building h8 and
wasn't able to so it was time for some
Parkour oh
a lot and eventually I decided to try to
start from a different building climb up
that one and then parkour from there
foreign
I didn't make it to the roof but I was
at least around 20 to 30 floors up
and while the game was glitching out
quite a bit I did manage to get this
shot which bear in mind wasn't even at
the roof
next I climb to the top of Minnie's Bay
which was much much easier to do and got
this shot as it turns out the shot from
Minnie's day roof is a near identical
angle to the shot from Lucy's roof
did the team take Liberties to just get
the most interesting shot for the anime
probably but it's still fun to try to
figure this out speaking of those
creative Liberties the inside of Lucy's
apartment complex while located in
Japantown is identical to the inside of
Judy's apartment complex from cyberpunk
2077 located in Watson's Kabuki try to
step inside Lucy's apartment and you'll
end up outside
episode 3 when David Goes to meet Maine
at a warehouse for his first gig this
Warehouse can be found at Santa
Domingo's Rancho Coronado or I should
say a warehouse that looks extremely
similar in a location that looks similar
in fact we can also find a Sixth Street
graffiti on the wall here which also
matches up with when the crew returned
back with the car and Bane explodes a
dude on a wall which is the same wall
with the Sixth Street graffiti the
arsaka driver and bodyguard drinks at a
bar after losing fights jacked and Coke
this bar minus the sign can be found in
Vista Del Rey Haywood there's also a gig
in there old friends which I also
decided to take a break and do
after stealing the car David and Lucy
Escape heading south on Congress with
the shot from the back of the car being
this
meanwhile the heavy traffic during the
chase scene can be found here
overlooking Mega building H6
finally the crew heads to Turbo's Diner
to celebrate finishing their mission
Turbo's Diner is in Japan Town Westbrook
near Lucy's apartment
next up episode 4 our first shots are in
the afterlife if you even play cyberpunk
2077 a little bit you'll know about the
afterlife is located in Little China
Watson
Maine and dorio are looking over
surveillance footage these cameras are
located in North Oak Westbrook near the
arasaki estate
[Music]
David heads out with the package to
deliver from all those Garage in Santa
Domingo's Rancho Coronado following the
paths of the West David passes by some
cops
[Music]
David heads to Rebecca and pilar's
apartment as a side note if any of my
pronunciations are weird I'm sorry I
watched the subtitled version of edge
Runners so I'm saying it kind of like
that and I'm not sure how the dub
version did it anyways Rebecca and
pilar's apartment is in Watson's north
side right next to the Longshore North
fast travel terminal
afterwards David meets up with Lucy at a
dock at night this dock is in City
Center's downtown area all the way to
the east it's also the location of the
gig the frolics of councilwoman Cole so
if you're looking to do their exact same
night run you might want to make sure
you're a high enough level to finish
this gig
up
they run south along the dock and
eventually end up at this location
[Music]
during this training montage we see
David now at the afterlife we also see
him at this gas station which would seem
to be the medesky fuel station located
in the Badlands we see brain dances at
Lizzie's bar located in Watson's Kabuki
Rebecca tries to teach David how to
shoot at a shooting range which just so
happens to be the Second Amendment
located in V's apartment
[Music]
there's the Maelstrom gang with their
insane visual implants at the all foods
Factory with the interior cash location
being identical to that of when Jackie
and V visit during the pickup near the
end of the episode after the Montage the
gang runs into a cyber psycho this cyber
psycho is located in North Side Watson
[Music]
the episode ends on the roof of Lucy's
apartment but I already went over this
finally for this video episode 5. The
Gang planned out how to capture Jimmy
Kurosaki in the location of one of the
very first missions of cyberpunk 2077.
this is in Japantown Westbrook on the
15th floor of one of the buildings if
you're having trouble refining it you
can get back in through the underground
garage
Jimmy Kurosaki or JK is at Embers which
is in the Glenn Haywood
when chasing JK there are a couple of
maps shown these maps are exactly in the
style of the maps from cyberpunk 2077
and actually map locations from the game
the location where JK is later killed is
in Watson's north side it's on the
second floor of one of the buildings
here
and there you go let me know if you'd
like to see the second half of the
season and once again major props of
volk.com I don't want to take any credit
away from their amazing work finding a
lot of these and I'll see you next time
later guys
thank you